hey there are sometimes important
political policy disagreements that we
have to talk about like I might disagree
with Donald Trump's policy on trade to
the extent that he understands it but
sometimes we just have to call out bad
people and people who are just lying and
there's been this backstory of criticism
from Donald Trump of President Barack
Obama who criticized him for years about
the amount of golfing that he did which
quite frankly it was relatively
infrequent particularly compared to the
amount that Donald Trump has been
golfing another narrative that Donald
Trump has tried to push is that he is
just the biggest supporter of the troops
the biggest supporter of the military
and it's recently been pointed out that
Donald Trump has not once gone and
actually visited our troops overseas
this is something that Barack Obama did
many times this is something that a
George W Bush did many times and most
people even if they disagree with
specific deployments that members of the
military are sent to would agree that
when you have a volunteer army as the
reason why we don't need a draft it
makes sense for presidents who were
deciding where our troops are deployed
to go and visit them it's not
necessarily a political statement about
what the troops are doing simply to say
the president decides where they go
the president should go and visit some
of the troops every once in a while and
during an Associated Press interview
last week it was pointed out to Donald
Trump that hey you haven't gone and
visited the troops at all Donald Trump
said that he is very busy with
everything that's taking place here to
go and visit the troops
Donald Trump has golfed almost 70 times
with over a hundred and fifty days of
visits to golf clubs Obama visited
troops within three months of taking
office I'm not talking about turning the
visiting of troops into some kind of
penis size contest it's about a truly
disingenuous person and Donald Trump
who's said during this interview with
the AP quote well I will do that at some
point but I don't think it's overly
necessary I've been very busy with
everything that's taking place here we
have the greatest economy in the history
of our country I mean this is the
greatest economy we've ever had
unemployment numbers many groups are you
know we've never even been close to
those numbers I'm doing a lot of things
I'm doing a lot of things but it's
something I do and do gladly he also
added later in the interview that no one
has been better at the military than him
I don't know what that means so there's
a couple theories here number one he's
scared like he's just genuinely scared
to go and visit troops where they are
stationed around the world that's one
possibility
second possibility is he knows that the
troops are increasingly not a friendly
group to him his approval among members
of the military is down to 44 percent
according to a Military Times pulled
down from around 50 percent this is very
low for a Republican president and
there's a really interesting element to
that poll which looks at approval by
branch and if you know anything about
military branches you won't be surprised
that it's the marine corps that has the
highest very favorable rating for Donald
Trump and in total between very
favorable and favorable something like
sixty four and a half percent or so 65
and a half percent of the marine corps
has a favorable view of Trump Navy and
Air Force have the least favorable view
of Trump obviously those bethe Navy and
Air Force people don't like Trump they
are losers and the Army's kind of in the
middle kneeling during the national
anthem we're supposed to believe is
disrespectful to the troops but being
the president and being too busy playing
golf to visit the troops is not
something that we should be horrified by
personally I think it's a mix of him
being too afraid to go to war zones eat
it after all dodge the draft five times
and him just not liking to travel too
much but also the point that he brought
up about the economy being so good that
he doesn't have to go visit the troops
over how is it really it doesn't hold up
right even if even if that's true when
she want them to share in the glory and
you know to give you one of your
campaign style rally speeches in front
of them you're right but he might as
well have brought up Hillary's emails I
mean it doesn't matter that it's
completely unrelated and and a
non-sequitur absolutely disgusting and
what really you know what we've talked
about how the farmers that
overwhelmingly supported Trump from the
Midwest in the election they're getting
crushed by Trump's Terrace right now
will they hold Trump and the Republican
policies that are hurting them
accountable in the midterm elections in
just a couple of weeks I don't know if
they will the military disgraced time
and again if I were in the military and
I saw that Trump claims he's too busy to
come visit me but he's playing golf
every week seemingly if I see that he is
ridiculing the parents of a deceased
fellow service member as he did multiple
times including with the family of
Captain kazeer Kahn uh I would say no
this is not a guy who is looking out for
the troops this is a guy who is actively
hostile and indifferent to the plight
and the day-to-day of what it means to
be in the military of the United States
will they hold him accountable at the
ballot box in November I hope so I don't
want to make any assumption right now I
hope that they will make sure you're
following the David Pakman show on
Instagram at David Pakman show
behind-the-scenes pictures there for my
weekend at politican in Los Angeles and
make sure you follow me on Instagram at
David Pakman one of today's sponsors is
Skillshare which is an amazing online
learning community that offers thousands
of high-quality classes on almost any
topic first 500 people who click the
link under this video will get two
entire months of totally free access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
they've got classes on everything from
design video editing photography
business technology cooking meditation
even classes on personal productivity I
know you'll be able to find something on
Skillshare that fascinates you or even
something that will help you in your
everyday life classes are taught by real
people who care about what they're
teaching I just took a really great
class on more advanced video editing
techniques the David Pakman show is
giving you two months of free access to
every class they offer when you click
the link under this video think about
everything you'll have at your
fingertips for two whole months totally
free hard to beat and after that if you
like it you can keep access to every
class on Skillshare for under ten bucks
a month one of the most affordable
learning platforms out there just click
the link under this video to redeem your
to three months of Skillshare but hurry
it's only available to the first 500 who
sign up